MALE SPEAKER: He's the
writer and sole custodian
of the popular blog
ListsOfNote.com.
And he spent a lot
of time hunting
down letters that people
have written over the years,
back when people wrote letters.
Some people here
remember that at least.
I won't embarrass anyone.
So last night, he comes from
an event in Southern California
with Julia Louis-Dreyfus, BJ
Novak, Dave Eggers, and Thandie
Newton, who were reading
some of these letters.
This was a charity event.
And Sean lives in
Manchester, England,
with his wife and children.
So let's give a warm
welcome to Shaun Usher.
[APPLAUSE]
So, Shaun, do you want to talk
about the event last night?
SHAUN USHER: Yeah, so this
is Letters Live, which
is a series of live events that
started when Letters of Note
first came out in the UK.
It's crazy.
So just famous people, these
really talented performers,
musicians, authors,
they get up on stage,
and they read out letters
from this book, as some of you
are about to do, I think.
And we've done about
12 of them in the UK.
And we've had people
like Benedict Cumberbatch
and Gillian Anderson, Nick Cave,
just these incredible people
just bringing these
letters to life.
And it's just been the
most rewarding experience.
So last night, we did the
first one outside of the UK
and in LA.
JJ Abrams read a letter.
Thandie Newton read a
couple, Julia Louis-Dreyfus.
And it's just the
most amazing night.
And then I got really drunk.
[LAUGHTER]
And I'm feeling quite
rough at the minute.
But it's great to be here.
And this is just
the latest chapter
of this strange existence.
MALE SPEAKER: So how did
you start doing this?
SHAUN USHER: I started
the website in 2009.
But if we go back 13
years when I first
met the lady who is now my
wife, two weeks after we started
dating, she moved away
to Spain for a year
as part of a university
course, which
should be the worst possible
start to a relationship.
But we decided to keep
in touch by letter.
So we wrote to each
other for 10, 11 months,
and we fell in love by
letter, really sickening.
But it was the best possible
start we could have had.
MALE SPEAKER: So none of
those letters are in the book,
though, right?
SHAUN USHER: I would never
publish those letters, no.
[LAUGHTER]
They're terrible.
But we learned so
much about each other,
far more than we would
have learned had we
been face to face, or
particularly communicating
by email or text message.
Because when you sit down
to write a letter, at least
with me and my wife
it's certainly the case,
you're far more willing
to be honest and open.
You'd say things
that you wouldn't
say in any other setting.
So by the end of that 10
months, we were best friends.
We'd fallen in love.
We were set up for life.
So that's when I was
bitten by the bug.
And I knew that I was going
to look into letter writing
as an art form at some point.
And then 2009 I
started the website,
and it just took off
really, really quickly,
such a simple idea.
The best ideas are.
I couldn't believe that no
one had done it already.
And yeah, I didn't really make
much effort to market the blog
or push it out there.
It did that by itself, thanks
to these amazing letters.
And then 2013, the book came
out after three years of slog.
Making a book like this
is a logistical nightmare,
because you have to get
so many permissions.
It's something
like 300 permission
we had to get for this.
And a lot of these people
that wrote these letters
are now dead, so you have
to deal with their estates,
and it's an absolute nightmare
getting decisions from people.
So I was so, so
proud of this book.
It's a beautiful thing.
It's been translated
into 18 languages.
The appeal of these
letters really
is universal and the
stories with them.
And just today, I've signed off.
We've just finished the second
"Letters of Note" book, which
will be out in the UK at the
end of this year and in the US--
I don't know when.
FEMALE SPEAKER: In April.
SHAUN USHER: April.
Thank you. [CHUCKLES]
So, yeah, my life
is dedicated to these letters.
And I couldn't be happier.
MALE SPEAKER: So
it's interesting
that you were writing letters
even though the internet was
around then and people
could text or email.
But what made you choose not to?
SHAUN USHER: It was exciting.
It was something different.
At this point, and this was
2000 and-- I don't know.
It was like 13 years ago.
So people were
emailing, obviously,
but not to the extent
that they are now.
We weren't using Twitter.
And just the idea of writing
letters to each other
was romantic.
So we just did,
and it was great.
And also, when
you email someone,
there's an expectation
that you're
going to reply within a
couple of days at the most.
If you don't reply
within a couple of days,
you're deemed rude.
But with a letter, you
can take anything up
to like a few weeks to reply,
and it's seemed acceptable.
And during those two weeks,
you can really, really
consider what
you're writing down.
It's a far more considered
form of correspondence.
And it brings out the best
in people and the worst.
MALE SPEAKER: Do you
find that other people
are willing to do
that as well nowadays?
SHAUN USHER: To write letters?
MALE SPEAKER: To
write letters, yeah.
SHAUN USHER: Well, I'm
probably not the best person
to ask, because I just speak
to people who love letters.
But since the blog started
and the book came out,
I'm contacted by loads of
people who love letter writing.
And this has kind of reignited
a passion they once had.
And I get contacted by loads of
teachers saying that they use
this book as a
teaching aid in school
either to teach about
letter writing itself
or to teach about
historical moments
that we wouldn't know about
were it not for these letters.
Reading letters
by someone who was
in the midst of these
historical events is,
I think, the most enjoyable
way to learn about history
from the front seat.
MALE SPEAKER:
Which are your-- we
have five people, counting me,
who are going to read letters.
Did you want to bring
them up, or did you
want to talk about some
of your favorites first?
SHAUN USHER: I'm easy.
Should I read one out?
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
SHAUN USHER: This is
the one I always choose.
It's a bit boring,
really, but this
is one of my favorite letters.
MALE SPEAKER: "I Like
Words," is that the one?
SHAUN USHER: It's
"I Like Words."
Should I read a
different one, then?
MALE SPEAKER: No, that's good.
SHAUN USHER: It's a
job application letter.
This was 1934.
There's a guy called
Robert Pirosh.
He was a copywriter.
When I first started Letters
of Note, I was a copywriter.
So I think that
kind of-- there's
a parallel there
that attracts me.
So 1934, he wanted to
become a screenwriter.
So he wrote this standard
form job application letter
and sent it to all the
movie studios and directors
he could find addresses for.
And this got him a job with MGM.
And he went on to
an Academy Award.
It's the perfect story.
And standard form job
application letters
aren't an easy letter to
make sexy, but he's done it.
And it was so successful.
It's quite compact.
"Dear Sir, I like words.
I like fat, buttery
words, such as ooze,
turpitude, gluttonous, toady.
I like solemn,
angular, creaky words,
such as straight-laced,
cantankerous, pecunious,
valedictory.
I like spurious, black-is-white
words, such as mortician,
liquidates,
tonsorial, demimonde.
I like suave, V-words,
such as Svengali,
svelte, bravura, verve.
I like crunchy, brittle,
crackly words, such as splinter,
grapple, jostle, crusty.
I like sullen,
crab-scowling words,
such as skulk,
glower, scabby, churl.
I like, oh-heavens,
my-gracious, land's-sake words,
such as trixie, tucker,
gentile, horrid.
I like elegant, flowery
words, such as estivates,
peregrinates, elysium, halcyon.
I like wormy, squirmy, mealy
words, such as crawl, blubber,
squeal, drip.
I like sniggly, chuckling
words, such as cowlick,
gurgle, bubble, and burp.
I like the word screenwriter
better than copywriter,
so I decided to quit my
job in a New York ad agency
and try my luck in Hollywood.
But before taking the
plunge, I went to Europe
for a year of study,
contemplation,
and horsing around.
I've just returned,
and I still like words.
May I have a few with you?
Robert Pirosh."
It's the perfect letter.
I absolutely adore it.
MALE SPEAKER: He got quite a
few responses to that, right?
SHAUN USHER: He did, yeah.
He got quite a few interviews
at different studios,
and he took a job with MGM.
And the rest is history.
I found that letter
in a really old book
that hardly anyone read.
So it was published
in 1970-something.
So yeah, quite a find.
MALE SPEAKER: How
about our readers?
FEMALE SPEAKER: Hi.
SHAUN USHER: Hi.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm Kate.
SHAUN USHER: So I was contacted
in 2011, I think it was,
by a lady who said, I've
got this amazing letter
written by Iggy Pop.
Do you want to see it?
An I'd seen a couple of
Iggy's letters before,
and they were great
but nothing special.
So she sent it to me and said
that, when I was a teenager,
I was having a terrible time.
My parents were splitting up.
We had bailiffs on the door.
I was really depressed.
I was near the end.
And at the time, Iggy
Pop on one of his albums
had printed his
address on the inlay
of this album for some
strange reason and said,
if you want to get in
touch, write to me,
and I'll try and
get back to you.
So she wrote to him and said,
I'm having a terrible time.
And he wrote this amazing,
really lovely letter back.
FEMALE SPEAKER: "Dear
Laurence, Thank you
for your gorgeous
and charming letter.
You brighten up my dim life.
I read the whole
fucking thing, dear.
Of course I'd love to see
you in your black dress
and your white socks, too.
But most of all, I want to
see you take a deep breath
and do whatever you must to
survive and find something
to be that you can love.
You're obviously a bright
fucking chick with a big heart,
too.
And I want to issue a belated
happy, happy, happy 21st b-day
and happy spirit.
I was miserable and fighting
hard on my 21st b-day, too.
People booed me on
the stage, and I
was staying in someone else's
house, and I was scared.
It's been a long
road since then,
but pressure never
ends in this life.
Perforation
problems, by the way,
means to me also the holes
that will exist in any story
we try to make of our lives.
So hang on, my love.
Grow big and strong, and take
your hits and keep going.
All my love to a really
beautiful girl-- that's you,
Laurence.
Iggy Pop."
[APPLAUSE]
SHAUN USHER: Thank you.
It's a lovely letter.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
Gloria.
SHAUN USHER: And
you're doing the--?
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm doing
the letter about Elvis
to President Eisenhower from
the teenagers in Montana.
SHAUN USHER: Oh, that one, yeah.
Yeah, brilliant.
So when he was called
up for service, Elvis,
the White House received
loads and loads of letters
from fans of Elvis
distraught that he was
about to be killed in battle.
But this particular letters
is one of my favorites,
because it's about something
slightly different.
MALE SPEAKER: Not just killed.
SHAUN USHER: Having
his head shaved, yeah.
FEMALE SPEAKER: "Dear President
Eisenhower, My girlfriends
and I are writing all
the way from Montana.
We think it's bad enough to
send Elvis Presley in the Army.
But if you cut his sideburns
off, we will just die.
You don't know how
we feel about him.
I really don't see why you have
to send him to the Army of all,
but we beg you, please, please
don't give him a GI haircut.
Oh, please, please don't.
If you do, we will
just about die.
Elvis Presley lovers,
Linda Kelly, Sherry Bane,
Mickie Mattson.
Presley, Presley is our
cry, P-R-E-S-L-E-Y."
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
SHAUN USHER: Who's next?
Samuel Barber, is it?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
This is-- Shaun?
SHAUN USHER: So
this Samuel Barber,
one of the greatest
musicians, composers,
wrote this letter to his mum.
Was it his mum or his parents?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
SHAUN USHER: It was
his mum, wasn't it?
MALE SPEAKER: Yes.
At the age of 9.
SHAUN USHER: Yeah,
at the age of 9.
It was quite
heartbreaking, I think.
MALE SPEAKER: "Notice to
Mother and nobody else.
Dear Mother, I have written this
to tell you my worrying secret.
Now, don't cry when
you read it, because it
is neither yours nor
my fault. I suppose
I will have to tell it
now without any nonsense.
To begin with, I was not
meant to be an athlete.
I was meant to be a composer
and will be, I'm sure.
I'll ask you one more thing.
Don't ask me to try to
forget this unpleasant thing
and go play football, please.
Sometimes I've been
worrying about this
so much that it makes
me mad-- not very.
Love, Sam Barber II."
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: The
question is, would he have
been a good football player?
[LAUGHTER]
SHAUN USHER: That was in the
book of his letters, I think.
There's a collection
of his letters, yeah.
So this was written by Elvis.
It was strange.
Well, his whole
life was strange,
but this was a particularly
stressful time in his life.
Elvis Presley used to
collect police badges,
and he wanted a police badge
from every different police
force in the US.
And the one badge
he couldn't get
was a badge from the FBI's
department of-- oh, my God,
what's it called?
The Narcotics--
MALE SPEAKER:
Bureau of Narcotics?
SHAUN USHER: Bureau
of Narcotics.
So the way he tried to get
one-- he successfully got one.
He travelled to the White
House on his personal jet.
And while he was
on the jet, he hand
wrote this letter
to Nixon, saying
I will be a federal
agent at large.
I will fight in the war
against drugs for you
so long as he could get a badge.
So he hand-delivered the
letter to the White House,
got a meeting with
Nixon, gave him a gun,
and got the badge
he'd always wanted.
And there's a very famous
photograph of Nixon and Elvis
in the Oval Office, I think.
And it's the most
requested photo.
MALE SPEAKER: Most requested
photo in the National Archives.
SHAUN USHER: In the history
of the National Archives,
all thanks to this crazy letter.
MALE SPEAKER: So let's see.
It says, "Dear Mr.
President"-- I'm not
going to do my Elvis
voice, by the way.
SHAUN USHER: Oh, go on.
MALE SPEAKER: Sorry if
you were counting on that.
"Dear Mr. President, First I
would like to introduce myself.
I am Elvis Presley and
admire you and have
great respect for your office.
I talked to Vice President Agnew
in Palm Springs three weeks ago
and expressed my
concerns for our country.
The drug culture, the
hippie elements, the SDS,
the Black Panthers,
et cetera, do not
consider me as their
enemy or, as they call it,
the Establishment.
I call it America,
and I love it.
Sir, I can and will
be of any service
that I can to help
the country out.
I have no concerns and motive
other than helping the country
out.
So I wish not to be given a
title or an appointed position.
I can and will do more if I were
made a federal agent at large.
And I will help out by doing it
my way through communications
with people of all ages.
First and foremost,
I am an entertainer.
But all I need is the
federal credentials.
I am on the plane with
Senator George Murphy,
and we have been
discussing the problems
that our country is faced with.
Sir, I am staying at the
Washington Hotel, Room 505,
506, and 507.
I have two men who work
with me by the name of Jerry
Shilling and Sunny West.
I am registered under the
name of John Burroughs.
I will be here for
as long as it takes
to get the credentials
of a federal agent.
I have done an in-depth
study of drug abuse
and communist
brainwashing techniques,
and I am right in the middle
of the whole thing, where I
can and will do the most good.
I'm glad to help, just as long
as it is kept very private.
You can have your staff or
whomever call me anytime
today, tonight, or tomorrow.
I was nominated this coming
year, one of America's 10 Most
Outstanding Young Men.
That would be in January
18 in my hometown
of Memphis, Tennessee.
I'm sending you a short
autobiography about myself
so you can better
understand this approach.
I would love to meet
you just to say hello
if you're not too busy.
Respectfully, Elvis Presley.
PS-- I believe
that you, Sir, were
one of the top 10 Outstanding
Men of America, also.
I have a personal
gift for you, also,
which I would like to present
to you, and you can accept it,
or I will keep it for you
until you can take it."
That was the Colt .45
that John mentioned.
[APPLAUSE]
So we have a letter from Elvis
and a letter about Elvis.
SHAUN USHER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Were there
other Elvis letters
that didn't make the cut?
SHAUN USHER: Not really, no.
There are load from
fans, obviously.
He had so many fans
it's ridiculous.
Stephanie's going to read the
John Steinbeck letter to his--
STEPHANIE: [INAUDIBLE]
MALE SPEAKER: --to
his 14-year-old son,
who was off at boarding school,
who said that he fell in
love with someone.
SHAUN USHER: Yeah, he
was lovesick and needed
some advice.
This is one of my
favorite letters.
STEPHANIE: So this
was my introduction
to Letters of Note on
Facebook, and I fell in love
with Letters of Note after that.
So it's from John
Steinbeck to Tom Steinbeck,
dated November 10, 1958.
"Dear Tom, We had your
letter this morning.
I will answer it from my
point of view and, of course,
Ellen from hers.
First, if you are in
love, that's a good thing.
That's about the best thing
that can happen to anyone.
Don't let anyone make it
small or light to you.
Second, there are
several kinds of love.
One is a selfish, mean,
grasping, egotistical thing,
which uses love for
self-importance.
This is the ugly
and crippling kind.
The other is an outpouring
of everything good in you,
of kindness and
consideration and respect,
not only the social
respect of manners,
but the greater
respect, which is
recognition of another person
as unique and valuable.
The first kind can make you
sick and small and weak,
but the second
can release in you
strength and
courage and goodness
and even wisdom you
didn't know you had.
You say this is not puppy love.
If you feel so deeply, of
course it isn't puppy love.
But I don't think you were
asking me what you feel.
You know better than anyone.
What you wanted me to help you
with is what to do about it.
And that, I can tell you.
Glory in it, for one thing,
and be very glad and grateful
for it.
The object of love is the
best and most beautiful.
Try to live up to it.
If you love someone, there is
no possible harm in saying so.
Only you must remember that
some people are very shy,
and sometimes the saying
must take that shyness
into consideration.
Girls have a way of knowing
or feeling what you feel,
but they usually
like to hear it also.
It sometimes happens
that what you feel
is not returned for
one reason or another.
But that does not make your
feeling less valuable and good.
Lastly, I know your
feeling, because I have it,
and I'm glad you have it.
We will be glad to meet Susan.
She will be very welcome.
But Elaine will make
all such arrangements,
because that is her province,
and she will be very glad to.
She knows about love,
too, and maybe she
can give you more
help than I can.
And don't worry about losing.
If it's right, it happens.
The main thing is not to hurry.
Nothing good gets away.
Love, Fa."
[APPLAUSE]
MALE SPEAKER: Let's see, we
talked about your favorites
already.
Have you found
anything especially
surprising or interesting
in going over this?
SHAUN USHER: Loads, yeah.
The Iggy Pop one was one
of the most surprising.
Not that I thought Iggy
Pop was a terrible person,
but I never thought
he would take his time
to respond to fans'
letters like that
at a time when he must have been
incredibly busy, presumably,
or wasted.
[LAUGHTER]
I didn't think he'd reply
to letters like that.
So that really surprised me.
There's a letter in the
book from Francis Crick, who
wrote to his son just
after he co-discovered
the structure of DNA before
it had been announced.
And he writes to his son and
he draws in a picture of the--
MALE SPEAKER: I
thought about that one,
but it was too long to read.
SHAUN USHER: Yeah, it's
not the best one to read,
but it's just such an
incredible letter, kind
of a monumental moment in time.
And that's the most
expensive letter ever sold.
And it sold just after I managed
to get it cleared for the book,
and it sold for 5 million pounds
at Christie's Auction House.
MALE SPEAKER: The Crick letter
is the most expensive one?
SHAUN USHER: Crick, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: Wow.
SHAUN USHER: Yeah, the most
expensive letter ever sold.
But it's an incredible thing.
And his family was
so pleased that it
was going to be in this book,
which is lovely when you speak
to someone's family
or estate and they're
pleased for the letter to go in.
MALE SPEAKER: Is
the son still alive,
the one that he wrote it to?
SHAUN USHER: Oh,
God, I don't know.
I think he is, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: So this letter,
by the way, if you get the book,
it's about four pages,
and he describes
what he found about DNA.
And it's full of diagrams and
chemical descriptions of it.
And it's amazingly
accurate even now, I mean,
because they nailed it, right?
SHAUN USHER: Yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: We started late,
but we have a question here
from Scott.
SCOTT: Have you found
letters and then
as you worked with them found
them to be fake or hoaxes?
SHAUN USHER: Not really, no.
I've been lucky.
Who knows?
Maybe there's some letters in
there that aren't actually--
maybe they are fake.
But I've not really
come across many, no.
SCOTT: That's more
of an internet thing.
SHAUN USHER: Yeah, it is, yeah.
I do, I take a lot of
time kind of verifying
the authenticity
of these letters,
because there are so many
fake ones flying around.
There's one by Stanley
Kubrick in which he supposedly
writes-- I can't remember
who he writes to,
but he lets off a lot of steam.
And that gets
circulated all the time.
There's another one supposedly
from Sean Connery to Steve
Jobs, I think it
was, which circulates
every couple of months.
And millions of people
probably think it's real.
MALE SPEAKER: That
one's fake, too?
SHAUN USHER: Yeah,
that's fake, yeah.
MALE SPEAKER: That was the
Kurt Vonnegut graduation
speech that never happened?
But I guess that
wasn't a letter.
But there was a letter from
Kurt Vonnegut in here, right?
SHAUN USHER: Yeah,
there's one in there.
There's one in the new
book as well, yeah.
His collection of letters that
came out a couple of years
ago is one of the best
books I've ever read.
STEPHANIE: Are there any
fascinating letters that you
were like, this should
be read by everybody,
but the estate has not
agreed to let you publish?
SHAUN USHER: Yeah, loads.
STEPHANIE: Tell us about it
even though we can't read them.
SHAUN USHER: Well, this
isn't really the same thing,
but there's a Frank Lloyd
Wright letter, the architect.
A little kid wrote to Frank
Lloyd Wright and said,
can you build a
house for my dog?
Can you design a
Because Frank Loyd Wright had
built a house for the family
years and years before.
And Frank Lloyd Wright wrote
back and said, yes, I'll
design your house.
So he designs him a house.
You can see a photo of
the doghouse in there.
But in the intro to the letter--
so I applied for permission
to use the letters in the book.
And the Frank Lloyd
Wright's estate said,
you can use it as long as
you take this one line out
of the intro, which was--
the dog hated the doghouse,
basically.
[LAUGHTER]
And he refused to
sleep in the doghouse.
And the last line in
the intro originality
was, the sting in the tail is
the dog hated the doghouse.
And the Frank Lloyd
Wright estate said,
you've got to take that
out, because we don't--
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE]
SHAUN USHER: It reflects
badly on Frank Lloyd Wright.
So now whenever I
talk about the book,
I make a point of telling
everyone about the dog.
MALE SPEAKER: If any of you
have been to Frank Lloyd Wright
houses or places like that,
this is a pretty funny picture,
because it looks just
like one of them. [LAUGHS]
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm the
publicist on the book,
but I do have a question
that has been in my mind.
So "Letters of Note," letters
are destined for someone else
to read, but in your new
book "Lists of Note,"
I'm guessing a lot of those
aren't meant for someone else
to read.
So how do you see the
difference between those two?
SHAUN USHER: Yeah, lists are
definitely more personal,
I think, than letters.
But I think they're
less precious.
I have less-- when I was
making "Letters of Note,"
I spent a lot of time
wondering whether I
should publish these letters,
even if I have permission.
A lot of them are sometimes a
bit too personal to publish.
But I've never had that
problem with lists.
I've never stopped and
thought, oh, my God,
should I publish this?
Although lists are
far more personal,
they're not as--
does that make sense?
They're not as
precious I don't think.
MALE SPEAKER: I
think we're done.
I'm just going to read
this very short list
by Preston Sturges of the 11
rules for box office appeal.
Since this is kind
of box office.
"Number one, a pretty girl
is better than an ugly one.
Two, a leg is
better than an arm.
Three, a bedroom is
better than a living room.
Four, an arrival is
better than a departure.
A birth is better than a death.
A chase is better than a chat.
A dog is better
than a landscape.
But a kitten is
better than a dog.
And a baby is better
than a kitten.
A kiss is better than a baby.
And a pratfall"-- I'm
not going to do one--
"is better than anything."
SHAUN USHER: So when I was
researching "Letters of Note,"
I was looking through
the archives and papers
of all these incredible people.
And I kept finding
lists, amazing lists,
along with these letters.
So that's how "Lists
of Note" came about.
And the first one I ever found
was the first list in the book
is a to-do list by Johnny Cash.
And he writes all these things
he has to do in the day,
like drink, eat, go for a
pee, kiss June, his wife, not
kiss anyone else.
And then the last thing
is "don't make lists."
MALE SPEAKER: "Number
one, not smoke.
Two, Kiss June.
Three, not Kiss anyone else.
Four, Cough.
Pee.
Eat.
Not eat too much.
Worry.
Go see Mama.
Practice piano.
And for notes, not write notes."
With that, let's thank
Shaun for coming.
[APPLAUSE]
SHAUN USHER: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: We
have books for sale,
and he'll be available
to sign them.
Thanks for coming, everybody.